welcome to film courage this is episode
159 and i'm karen warden and i'm david
brandon you can find our archives on
itunes filmcurse.com
latalkradio.com
and moviegarage so at this year's ted
conference youtube's trend manager kevin
aloca spoke about what makes a video
viral referring to today's film courage
guest paul yosemite bear vasquez the
double rainbow guy that that video is
how we discover discover paul um in july
2010 one of jimmy kimmel's staffers
uh caught wind of bear's double rainbow
video which jimmy kimmel tweeted
inviting bear in the show shortly after
the video success um within days i mean
the the video blew up had millions of
views and and his life has forever been
changed and to date the video now has
over 33 million views bear has traveled
the world with speaking engagements
interviews a television commercial with
jennifer aniston microsoft and more bear
prefers the natural beauty and wonder of
yosemite california where he can be
close to spirit
family his animals and farm
and despite his celebrity and being one
of um you know one of google's or one of
the one of the most groups i want to say
individuals in july of 2010 please
welcome to film courage paul yosemite
bear vasquez hello bear how are you
hello wait a second i'm i'm i'm asleep
at the wheel okay well you know it is
easter so the mimosas here we go
good morning here i apologize for that
oh that was great
good morning good morning
it's great now i understand from
watching your youtube channel that you
are in the middle of a juice fast how's
that going oh that's right yeah i'm on
day six
wow how do you feel do you feel kind of
more like your
um senses are heightened or what do you
feel
oh i feel really energized i'm surprised
i'm surprised that i'm not hungry yeah
it's um
it's brought a lot of clarity to me and
i don't know i haven't watched the scale
but um
my daughter said i looked thinner so uh
you know we'll see i guess but uh yeah i
feel real energized and uh it's it's
really neat and i'm i'm being guided to
a fellow youtuber with it and um she's
lost 50 pounds you know doing it so it's
it's a fascinating thing and that's mia
right mia yeah that's mia yeah yeah
samia sampson oh cool yeah and is that
your motivation bear is that is that
something is it the weight loss or is it
is it
what is it exactly
well yeah it's definitely weight loss
because you know i've struggled with
obesity my whole life and you know
something that's going to end my life a
lot shorter if i don't uh do something
about it
well for those of you listening uh
please go over to bear's youtube channel
and again that's hungrybear9562
and you can see why bear has the
following that he does i mean there's so
many short videos um of his life ranging
from funny to you know in-depth and
spiritual to some very emotion-filled
ones it was home i do want to make
everyone aware that we do have jonathan
schieffer here in studio with us a
filmmaker
for you know formerly currently known as
spiritus bolt you can you can follow him
on twitter at jay schieffer um and we
just welcome you to the studio as well
thank you jonathan thank you it's a
pleasure great great having you
so he's going to be throwing throwing
some you know it's doing his research
yeah we've already mentioned we're going
to triple team bear today so yeah he's
going to he's going to take part
having some fun
um since um you know i want to start
with this bear since the video has gone
viral
is there one day that passes where
literally it doesn't come up at all
no
isn't that something it's it's all
inclusive in my life it's you know it's
mind-boggling yeah it's always offers
and people contacted me on the phone
it's a non-stop stream of humanities
consciousness flowing into me
and and and today i mean do you still
watch the double rainbow video or no you
know i don't i i don't watch it very
often at all i watch it when people come
over um
you know i watch it like when i just do
a tv appearance or something like that
yeah it's not something that i watch
very often because it evokes a very
powerful response in me
well bear on our youtube channel we
posted an interview with filmmaker joe
wilson a vampire mob his web series
entitled no one can make a viral video
and in the video joe states exactly that
you know no one can intentionally create
a viral video we just want to present
this to someone who has accidentally
created such an experience is it
possible for someone out there to sort
of brainstorm and get a video to go
viral i mean we see these cat videos we
see these dancing babies
and
is it possible or is it is it just sort
of an act of nature
if you spend millions of dollars you can
do it i mean they did it with jennifer
aniston and you know they they i i did
this shoot with her
and um
you know they had
it was over a hundred people there and
you know it was a high budget thing and
you know they called it jennifer addison
sex tape and since it was jennifer
aniston and they had all these viral
video stars on it they got 10 million
views so
yeah if you spend you know millions of
dollars on uh on a production yeah you
can do it but
i did it for free
right so yeah you can't intend it you
can't it just has to happen
interesting sex tape so you don't you
don't think you can create it i mean
because you know
you i mean you've also met a lot of
people within the youtube community you
know i mean so you know you've met some
of the most popular people on youtube i
mean so do you think anyone's starting
from scratch if they set out like this
is something that i'm going to do do you
think it will happen or you think
they're that they would just be chasing
the wildest of dreams
um i think you can't want it you think
if you want it then it's it can't happen
i think that if you
uh like see all i was doing was was um
was serving my fellow man i was
witnessing something that was pure and
natural and being open and honest you
know you can't you can't want it if it
if um if you want it it can't come you
have to you have to do it as part of
service so i
i don't think that it can happen that
way you know it's just and it i don't
think there's a formula for it so it's
tough it's tough to say that and i think
people are trying to chase it down and
and maybe there someday it will come
that someone can figure out the formula
but i don't know that that's possible
you know what what i love about the
success of the double rainbow video is
the work that you put in behind the
scenes and that's something that a lot
of people may not realize you know you
posted the video in january of 2010
it wasn't until you know july
of 2010 that that it sort of exploded on
the scene but there was some work that
you had done in between there and in
terms of you going to visit the jimmy
kimmel show like
when when did that happen when when did
you go
the first appearance on jimmy kimmel um
you know when you didn't have the shirt
you know when when was that when you
when you when you did that
so i i went to jimmy's i drove by
hollywood boulevard and saw jimmy's line
and said oh there's some power there and
went and signed up for tickets and said
you know
and went in his audience and made my
presence known and
i was just like following what was in
front of me and like didn't have any of
this intended i was just doing what was
in front of me and and i guess i was
being guided i was being guided by
spirit so that you know that was in 2010
like what what years before oh wait
it was was that the same year was that
before you posted the the video that was
two years before yeah that was 2000 2008
oh that was
they were able to 2010.
so and you know when i went on jimmy
kimmel he was like oh yeah i guess maybe
spirit is guiding you because like it
was all this was all like predestined
because you know that's how they found
my video because i shot that i caught
that on my dvr and i put that on my
youtube channel and they they saw
they saw that clip and they said oh
let's see what else he's got on his
youtube channel and they saw the double
rainbow video
so it's not like i shot the double
rainbow video and i went and jimmy
kimmel and and made it all happen no it
was all
that i went in on his show first
right and and
and you know um
made that made that video of me on his
show
so it wasn't like i was trying to
promote the double rainbow video
okay
yeah i'm wondering bear though what
would you be doing now if this had never
happened with jimmy i mean have you
thought about how your life would have
turned out like i'd be doing the same
thing i'm doing now except not talking
to you i'd be working my farm
uh yeah
right okay so in you right photography
and just living in beautiful
surroundings i gotcha okay yeah i would
have went to the bear ceremony last
night right
you know working
yeah farming um yeah that's it okay you
know let's talk a little bit how life
has changed i mean how many how many
people i mean can you guesstimate or
estimate how many people you've
interviewed with
since since the video went viral
i'd say over 300 300 300 interviews all
over the world wow so the standard yeah
yeah that's over 300 in the last two
years i mean how many how many press
opportunities have you turned down you
said you know what
i don't i don't like your vibe i'm not
going to do that particular interview or
or president
oh wow so you have turned down just a
handful
interesting yeah yeah because um
spirit told me that i'm supposed to
spread this message and the only reasons
i turned it down was it was a conflict
it was a conflict because it was timing
i was doing two at once you know i was
like oh i was already busy
so i i made myself available at all
times of the day all hours i never said
no if the only reason i couldn't do is
because i was already doing something
and and money was never an issue i would
i never charged for anything you know if
someone was going to make some money off
of it then they needed to give me some
but i never made it about oh you have to
pay me bear i i was watching your uh
your videos and i noticed that um you're
very open and honest and it really made
me
excited to talk to you today um
one of the things i was wondering is is
you have a lifestyle that seems kind of
like
wanting to to be in touch with nature
and then you have this other side that's
very into technology and posting things
on youtube and i was
i'd like to just get get get to know a
little bit more about how you think
about it how about those two worlds
together
so i mean i was born and raised in l.a
and then i came to yosemite to live and
work in 1985.
so it's like i have both worlds and then
i bought this farm and i also have
high-speed internet i'm i'm in the
middle of nowhere but i'm connected so
it's like i have everything you know i
have i have this peace and solitude but
i'm also connected so it's like i have
like the best of both worlds so
it's like i was the i was the perfect
person to do this because i am open to
spirit but i'm also connected to
humanity
it's powerful stuff that's really cool
i just want to come back to just real
quick bear you know what
when all these people approach you you
know like when when the kind folks from
film courage reach out to you and say
hey you know what you know let we want
to talk with you you know
you're not at a point yet where you know
you're like you know what i'm tired
about i'm tired of talking about the
same thing over and over again so you i
mean you're not tired of it in any way
at this point 300. i never get tired i
am tireless
no i i am a servant i am a
i'm a vessel spirit of servant of
mankind i am i am here to spread the
message and um i have unlimited energy
no i never get tired
yeah in the first six weeks it was
phenomenal i was doing five six
interviews a day at all hours of the
night some of the big ones they said oh
we want you up at one in the morning and
i would like go to sleep with the phone
in my hand and i would wake up at one in
the morning and do it and sometimes i
had to be up all night to do it and you
know i would wake up at seven in the
morning and just do an interview and
then go back to sleep and do another one
a couple hours later and you know i i
just worked tirelessly i've that's one
thing about me i have so much energy i
could just bounce it out
and because you had this this like
dramatic shift in sort of your life how
are people around you reacting was it
scary for them
or was it fun for them or they were just
in awe watching it
because you know i've always had this
really intense life and i'm always with
this i've always been this really
intense person you know i was a cage
fighter and you know uh
so
people
that are around me and it's like oh it's
just another thing you know it's like
you know it's just it's just another
thing that's in this amazing guy's life
so yeah it's it's nothing that is out of
step with who i am
okay
and we are on the line with paul
yosemite bear vasquez also known for his
viral hit video yosemite bear mountain
giant double rainbow 1 8 10.
you know so bear since the explosion of
the double rainbow video
is life better for you
are you having more fun with it do you
feel sort of a greater sense of
fulfillment because you are able to
spread the message of spirit or or has
it been a little overwhelming
um there's been a couple of overwhelming
things
when i was on stage at vidcon there was
thousands of people singing my words
that was kind of overwhelming and then
when a high school in iceland raised
money to bring me out there and they did
a festival where they sang and dance and
um they did a play and then they
these high school kids surrounded me and
they were all hugging and kissing me and
that was hard to understand
so that was and then hugging jennifer
aniston that was kind of
hard to understand those three things
probably were like a little over the top
but everything else uh you know i uh i
get mobbed a lot you know people stop
but you know it's all fun and you know
i'm a cage fighter i'm tough you know so
nothing intimidates me nothing scares me
you know so um
yeah it's i take it all you know it's
like oh this is cool you know i enjoy i
enjoy life so whatever comes i'm happy
with it cool you know so many people
want you know they want that fame they
want to be famous what would you tell
them about success good or bad
you can't want it i never did i never
wanted i you know when you look at my
video it's obvious i didn't try i didn't
want it it's you know it's not set up it
you don't even see me in that video you
know it's it's a reaction and i'm i'm
just open and pure and honest and brave
to put it on there so um
that's the thing you have to let go you
can't want you have to let go of wanting
and you have to just love and appreciate
that's what i'm doing in that video i'm
just appreciating and i'm loving
something that's beautiful in my front
yard
yeah bear when i when i first saw your
channel i i thought that maybe it was
kind of like the kind of person who who
stumbled across a video and made it
awesome and then and and got huge
and because of all the followers began
to do a youtube channel but that's not
what i saw with you i saw that you were
doing videos prior to that and this was
just kind of like one among many
that's true i you know i was doing
videos from the 80s and i couldn't wait
to get on youtube
you know i i was uh shooting video when
they when the video cameras first came
out and i had an editing vcr and i was
mixing uh videos and mixing sound and
all that and as soon as youtube came out
i was like oh you this is me you know
and so um
youtube was made for me
yeah
so you're a filmmaker bear you're a
filmmaker
it's true i have a story to tell
you know you know spiritually you know
going back but before before the video
you know where was your life at leading
up
to to sort of the explosion i mean you
know
were you in a good place uh you know um
you know spiritually you know you know
financially i mean you know
can you take us back before the video
so um well it's an interesting story i
mean i was raised in l.a i lived in
alley till i was 22 and then i moved to
yosemite in 1985 to live and work in the
park and i bought this land in 1988 and
it turned it into organic farm and i
worked in yosemite from
85 to
94 and i drove long haul truck from 94
to 2004
and
in 2004 i was 465
and i was gonna die of obesity so um
i realized that i had a stop driving
truck so i i um
i sold my truck and i bought photography
equipment i bought computers and i
brought bought dogs and i was like okay
i'm just gonna breed dogs i'm gonna you
know grow vegetables and fruit and i'm
gonna do photography and video and try
and make a living that way and i'm gonna
try and lose weight and then i thought
well if i'm gonna lose weight i'm gonna
i'm gonna have to fight for my life i'm
gonna fight for real i'm going to get
into cage fighting and i mean this is
all a really interesting story and you
know and then i'm going to document it
all and um and so i didn't make very
much money from you know when i stopped
driving truck but my place was all paid
for so yeah from 2004 till like when i
went viral i i lived on 6 000 a year or
less
just from selling my dogs and from my
photography business so yeah i was
really poor for a long time but it's all
a real interesting story and it's all in
my videos
you know
where where did they come from in terms
of
you know
was this something that was always
inside you with with wanting to to have
the video equipment and
you know that that whole side of it like
where did that come from i saw myself on
video i said oh my god
that's me i need to do that someone took
a video of me riding my motorcycle like
in the 80s or as soon as video came out
i was like i need to have a video camera
and
i took a credit card out and i and uh i
put a hat in the local paper saying i
will videotape your event for free and
i'll sell you the tapes for twenty
dollars and i would go into videotape
events and sell tapes for and i would
you know sell tapes for twenty dollars
and i would make you know two three
hundred dollars and i paid for my
equipment that way and you know i didn't
make very much money but i made enough
to buy more equipment and you know i
would i bought enough equipment to so i
had really good equipment and
so you know i wasn't making a whole
bunch of money but i made enough to work
i could really do this really good and
so it got me into it you know it was
like i was just drawn to this medium
bear i want to go back to your intuition
for a minute because i'm so fascinated
by it and you mentioned in
i think you mentioned this in your bio
on your site and you also mentioned this
in the article you just did for our site
that you were able to feel how
humanity was viewing you um once the the
rainbow video went viral being as
intuitive as you are how do you handle
it if you pick up negativity how do you
filter that out you said that most the
time it's been positive and all that but
i'm sure there are times when there's
just somebody that's in a dark place and
they're going to want to fight they're
going to come at you so how do you
filter that out
yeah so you call those people trolls and
you know all of that is uh i love it
all of that is it's about them you know
and um
you just realize that you know so if
someone comes after you
you realize that it's they're
they're pathetic people and they're
they're
you know
they're feeling bad about themselves and
so it's not about you so
whenever someone attacks me it's like i
know that they're they're pathetic
creatures you know and it's always a
hundred percent they don't have a
profile picture and they don't have any
videos so so they're
horrible miserable people who live in
toilets
what about when you're out in the world
like for me you know like going to i
don't know if you've ever been to
hollywood in highland but it's like a
vortex of energy and for me it's a lot
to handle do you ever have that happen
where it's just too much and you've like
you know what i want to go back to the
solitude of nature or are you able to
sort of ground yourself
when you're in those public settings and
you just feel energy just coming at you
the energy flows through me and i can
really handle it i don't like traffic i
don't like cars and all that but humans
i love that energy and it's never
negative and i'm like the worst person
to mess with i'm a big giant cave
fighter i'm 350 pounds and i'm a tr i'm
trained in jiu jitsu and boxing and all
that so no one ever messes with me you
know and if you did it's like it would
be over so quick
you know what i mean and so many people
love me it would be you know everyone
would defend me so quick you know so
yeah i never get any negative energy
toward me in public and um and if i did
it's like i'm so protected by so many
things that yeah nothing bad would ever
happen to me
and do you have a process of how you let
things flow through you can you can you
take us through that or is it just so
instinctual that it's even hard to just
put into words it's just been a it's
been a lifelong process of learning that
and you know okay so martial arts has
been a something that i've been
training in for a long time and that's a
big part of it you know martial arts
trains you in that and it becomes
ingrained in you because part of your
reality part of your way of thinking and
people sense that and they and you know
when you're 350 pounds people
you know you just put off this aura and
you're so big and powerful people don't
mess with you and they don't even think
about messing with you okay
you know what that's sort of a
fascinating
um endorsement uh for martial arts there
i like that
you know bear does does everyone have
the power to connect with their own
success you know for you
you you've gained this enormous
popularity from the double rainbow video
and then you know and then people become
intrigued by you and your subsequent
videos that you have online and just you
know just people become fascinated just
watching your life on youtube but but
what about for for the struggling
artists out there who still haven't
gotten there yet they still haven't sort
of crossed over and and they're sort of
trying to live out their dreams you know
do you believe they have it in them to
connect with their own success
so i'm only human you know so the thing
about me is
i i don't make it about me i make it
about my service to my fellow human
beings and if you can do that if you can
make it about not want it if you can
make it about i want to serve my fellow
human beings i want to give my art my
soul to my humans because i love
then powerful powerful things can happen
right
one of the things that i noticed in your
videos is is you seem to be tremendously
open and genuine and it was it at first
i thought it was kind of like
a uh
an act but the more i watched it i mean
i i really believe that you you you you
are who you say you are
and i mean you have videos that are that
are like too long to fake and one of the
moments that really struck me as
powerful and open
was uh
you talked about
uh
this moment where you you
one of your catch phrases is i uh what
does this mean and you said that you
can't say that anymore without thinking
about
the video
and i was i was i was wondering um is
there a point or a series of points
choices maybe that you made that led you
to this
this open and honest way of seeing the
world and and of of of living
well coming to live in yosemite
saturday's so powerful you know it's so
beautiful people come here from all over
the world just to like get a glimpse of
it you know they they come
and it's like oh i can spend two you
know two or three days here and i live
i've been living here since 1985 and i
practiced the yosemite indian ceremonies
and cultures here you know i'm immersed
in it and i walk around there and people
it's like oh he's a yosemite legend you
know and and i have this farm here
that's right near the park you know
that's a big part of it you know that
that
coming coming and living near this the
it's the center of the universe you know
that that has been a big part of it and
then having this farm not you know out
in the middle of nature that's a big
part of it too you know
people send me uh videos of rainbows and
they're always with
with buildings or or telephone wires or
they're you know they're in traffic you
don't see any rainbow videos with just
nature like mine
so
being in nature like that that's huge so
even if you live in the city if you can
get out in nature that you know that
that's a big part of it so yeah being in
nature that that helps
well that question actually jonathan
segways perfectly into what we were
going to ask about
you know we do see uber as being very
open and we see this beautiful life that
you have and your your beautiful
children in the videos
and it feels like we know you it feels
like hey we're friends and all this
stuff and i'm sure there's people out
there on the internet and not not trolls
but nice people but maybe they they feel
like they know you but the thing is
there's like this line though because
you still have your life and you still
have your right to privacy
how do you how do you kind of keep those
boundaries in place while being friendly
and not hurting people's feelings
because i'm sure people probably come at
you like oh bear we're friends we know
you
yeah well they are my friends and they
come and visit me okay so you're okay
with that all right so so there's i mean
i spend time with them i go visit them
they come and visit me they're my
friends we talk yeah
okay that's another thing that i wanted
to talk about is how this the youtube
and the internet are expanding
humanity's consciousness and it's it's
changing who we are as humans we are we
are evolving into this creature that it
we're like more united now and so it's
not just oh the the internet is this
thing now it's we're we're united on the
internet and
youtube is our memory and facebook is
like how we talk
so yeah
it's not i don't have these boundaries
yeah okay
you have to get my permission to come up
here and visit my house but yeah if you
do i've
so many countless people have come and
visited me and i go visit them and you
know we i meet a lot of them you know
they come and stay with me i have one
here now yeah mia very cool yeah we
started the videos hi mia
well and in keeping with that for the
messages that you've received from
spirit
are there things that we need to know
does humanity i mean you've you've kind
of talked about that concerning
alternative energy what are some of the
messages that you're receiving about
that humanity needs to know about right
now where we're headed well the the
stuff about food is really important you
know like fast food is dangerous sugar
is dangerous um
uh we need to get back to like organic
farms and organic ways of eating or
energy we need to get off of foreign oil
we need to get onto alternative energy
because there's it's gonna happen and
the sooner that we we figure it out the
sooner we get onto solar and wind and
all those others the better because
because if we wait too long it's going
to be it's going to be really bad
because people are going to suffer so if
we figure it out now and say oh we we
need to start this now then less people
are going to suffer
okay so those are two big two of the
biggest ones energy and food
and then if we can get on energy now
then we'll we'll be rich i talk about
this in this uh bear for president video
you know we
we can we can be rich again if we start
spending the money
uh on alternative energy on the
infrastructure that we need to uh
transmit the solar and the wind if we do
that here now then we stop polluting
ourselves with uh foreign oil and and
you know put americans back to work
building that infrastructure we'll have
money for health care we'll have money
to reform the prison systems so you know
i mean those two things are the biggest
ones food and energy okay
and i'm wondering too
what
when in your life did you start
receiving these sort of intuitive
downloads if you want to call them i
mean was it once you got to yosemite and
maybe things were just more serene or
have you experienced this since the time
you were a little boy
um i um i have well i have to say i was
like always a really spiritual person i
like i started dragging my my mother to
church when i was a little kid and i was
always exploring different religions i
went through a lot of different
religions i was always seeking
spirituality and then when i came to
yosemite it's like i started to get into
the the ceremonies and culture so it's
it's been a long slow progression and um
so you know um it's just been something
who i am and it just keeps
continuing and progressing
you know you had mentioned this this uh
you know sort of shift in in global
consciousness i mean do you think that's
happening right now are we are we seeing
a shift in global consciousness
it's already happened you know and and
and people are people are not realizing
that it's happened but they're going to
realize that it happened but with the
with the internet people are real are
are connecting and and one of the things
that i saw is um
i had a friend here and she was sitting
on my front yard and i
i posted on
on my facebook page that i needed to let
my chickens out and she's sitting in my
front yard and she goes when are you
gonna let your chickens out and it was
like whoa
you know because she
she didn't have her computer but she
understood that
and it's like
she's on facebook right but she's not
she didn't have her computer with her
so she's tapped into that consciousness
even without that computer so that
that's happening that's where we're
going we're we're in that consciousness
and we're going there we're going we're
going to go there without our computers
well you mentioned too that that's
something that seems to happen to you a
lot that sort of anybody in your circle
they're sort of like this you almost tap
into like the same mindset can you just
touch on that first time yeah you know
some of the the people that i'm really
close to you know we we're on the same
level we kind of like we connect we
communicate without without talking
without
uh actually having to
do it you know
on facebook we kind of just know what's
going on like uh i have a video where
i'm talking about my daughter and the
second i say her name the phone rings
and it's her oh wow
yeah so you know it's stuff like that
no it sounds like my relationship with
karen you know you know we're constantly
yeah
yeah it's there people just don't
realize yeah it's there
you know it's so interesting barry
because here you are you're in the
middle of nature and yet you do have
sort of the high-speed internet um that
that you've mentioned
how plugged in are you because
what's amazing is is here you are in
nature but you comment frequently on
your youtube page you know if someone
comments you're likely to comment back
you you've been terrific keeping up with
emails as leading up to this show so how
much of it is you enjoying nature
throughout the day and how much is it is
you being plugged in online
well i'm in my front yard right now
oh really
you like that i love it it's awesome
yeah you can be in my front yard on a
laptop and uh you actually wear the
double rainbow video with shot you can
be on your laptop uh without without
wires without without uh
you can be on your wi-fi without you
know if you're running on your battery
yeah you could be walking around i could
be
showing you that on uh
uh on skype anywhere in the world
without uh without electricity without
yeah that's what it's like
but but is your day is your day like our
day where you're where you're just on
that computer for just hours and hours
every day
um yeah it can be that and then i also
have to go and come and take care of my
animals i have chickens and and dogs and
then i have all kinds of plants so it's
mixed and then you know i gotta i ride
my motorcycle and i gotta go to town and
so it's both but yeah i am on hours and
hours every day i have so much coming
into me i have to take care of that but
so it's both
hmm
yeah well from watching the videos i've
been telling dave like i want to move to
yosemite like it just i want to live
somewhere rural like that it looks so
cool and and i'm wondering what is the
most common response you get from people
um who who've seen your youtube channel
and essentially are following your life
that this is an amazing place and you
know i spent 10 years driving truck 48
states in canada and i looked for a
better place than here and i couldn't
find it you know i i was born and raised
in l.a and i loved it and i came up here
and i was like ooh this is a better
place and i bought this farm and when i
when i drove truck i was like
i'm going to look for if there's any
other better place and i had all this
criteria you know
uh weather
uh politics pollution crime it was a
whole long list and no place came close
to this place it's just it's just
fantastic great weather you know we're
in california which you know california
is the leading as far as humanity's
consciousness you know all the ideas
start here you know
film technology
you know everyone thinks that california
is where it starts so yeah and then the
weather here and the affordability of
this place it's fantastic and the people
here they're like-minded here they know
that something's coming and they're
preparing
one of the things uh that i've that i've
noticed in in your videos bear is that
um
your
rainbow video enabled you to really be
invited into places that you we we might
not normally get to see and one of those
places that i saw uh was
when you visited the occupy oakland and
i was wondering um if you could talk
about the like the different maybe vibe
that you got because there was a section
of the video
where they were sprinkling the mud
and then there was another section where
you were sitting on stage behind the
speakers and i was just wondering if you
could talk about the different
spirits for lack of a better word of
those two environments yeah so i mean
you know i saw this movement going on i
thought you know what i need to go
lend my lend myself to that and see what
i can do just document my part and um
and i can see how
like the people were there and that's
where that's where i was i felt that i
was part of the people but then in the
background you could see like they were
doing like like you said they were
sprinkling that so you could tell like
from underground uh the the politicians
they didn't like any of that you know
and and when i was there i didn't i
didn't experience very much of it
firsthand but like the day i before i
got there they had beat up so many
people you know so like i didn't
experience the fir the negativity
firsthand and the
and the the brutality firsthand but it
was there and and um
uh uh you know there's like all this
oppression going on and um i didn't see
very much of it i just saw a very little
taste of it and in in that video you see
me like uh shooting the helicopter you
know there's a helicopter watching it
and yeah the little sprinkler so i'm
just getting a little little flavorings
of it you know but mostly and you know
there's cops around i get little shots
of that but when i was there i didn't i
didn't see very much of that it i don't
know if it's because i was there or
whatever you know but that's what it was
my experience was like
you know you you say that the double
rainbow uh video you know the lessons
that you got out of it or the messages
you're supposed to share it boils down
to three main messages love your fellow
man walk gently in mother earth mother
earth and and connect to spirit
i want to talk about connective spirit
what what does that really mean
uh baron and how do you do that how do
you connect the spirit
so spirit is all around us spirit is
some people call it god some people call
it mother nature
spirit is something other than yourself
spirit can also be your fellow man if
you can love your fellow man you know
then that's that's good enough if you
can treat your fellow man like if that
person is god then you're connecting to
spirit and another way to do it is to
just get out in nature and appreciate it
you know if you can go look at a rainbow
and go oh my god that's so beautiful
then you're doing it you know and and
the thing that's been powerful to me is
people see rainbows now and they start
saying my words so even though maybe
they're not really believing it at least
they're mouthing it you know so and
that's how i started to transform my
life
i
i i wanted to be a more generous person
and i wasn't and i forced myself to to
be and and now i am because i forced it
and and people are seeing rainbows and
they're saying these words
and it's forcing it it's they're doing
it so if people can start to do it then
they're going down that path
can you tell us how you forced yourself
i find that fascinating because there's
a lot of people especially now with well
they say we're out of a recession but
things are still really tough and people
are sort of beaten down emotionally how
would we resurrect ourselves if we're in
that funk
so um
i mean uh how i forced myself to be
generous is i started giving stuff away
you know i mean it's like
in my nature i grew up in east la you
know and it was a it was a violent place
and my nature was to oh i wanted to get
over on everyone and no one was going to
be able to get over on me and and i was
like
i didn't like who i was so i'm going to
just give i'm going to give if someone
i'm going to give the shirt off my back
if if someone if someone needs it you
know and and it didn't feel good it
would hurt but i was like i want to
change who i am and so um you know it it
if you um if you
and if you're heavy if you're if you're
obese it doesn't feel good to walk
but if you force yourself you'll become
not heavy so you have to force the
things that you want you don't want to
do if you're sad if you're depressed and
you laugh and you force yourself to
laugh you'll become not depressed and
you you know it doesn't seem like that's
possible that that's true but it is if
you if you're sad if you're depressed
and you laugh hard even if it's fake
you will change
i love it
i love it i mean it's it's interesting
because you're you're isolated in nature
you're miles away from people but people
are so drawn to you and and in almost
every one of your videos there's the the
woofer girls that are there working on
your farm you got all these people
can you explain
you're a chick magnet yeah no i mean
just all this stuff can you explain this
this vortex of i mean you know we see it
but i'm just wondering why
what your take is i mean everybody's so
drawn to you you know
it's because i
i do not want i accept and i appreciate
and and i'm a gentleman you know and uh
and i don't i i don't uh i don't want
sex from these women i just i just love
you know i don't hit on them you know
and and i have a good set of references
you know and um
and and
it's it's beautiful here you know and
i'm a magic man and and when you have
all these things people are drawn to you
and and all these you know women were
coming here before i got famous
you know so it's not because i'm famous
okay
okay well you make people feel good
that's that's great yeah and you know
you have to not you have to be a
gentleman that's the biggest part and
when when it first started i would tell
the women who are coming here that i
would i will treat you like i would want
any man to treat my daughter and and
that protects my daughter that brings
karma on my daughter and you know and so
if i'm gonna treat i might not treat you
like i would want some other man to
treat my daughter of course i'm gonna
treat them kindly and with respect and
then my daughter travels all over the
world she's going to be protected
because then some other man is going to
treat her like i treat this young woman
no that's great i love it yeah that's
really nice you know and
as we wrap up the show bear you would
love to hear like what's sort of like
the next phase what's the next adventure
where we're where
what can we expect i mean i mean are do
you plan a year ahead a year ahead of
time five years ahead of time or can you
tell us about what's going to happen
next yeah road tour i just i just do
whatever's in front of me if someone you
know someone offers me something then
you know i accept and and then i just
plan that so you know i'm going to uh
ralph in boston uh next month and then
i'm going to vidcon in july and so those
are things that i'm really looking
forward to uh i uh i went to vidcon last
year and now i was so phenomenal and and
this year they're giving me a room so
i'm really excited about that one of my
favorite videos is me on stage at vidcon
last year i i recommend everyone go see
that because that is so powerful
so uh yeah those are the two things but
other than that it's just my farm and
living my life and and and how oh so the
one of the things that we're pro that
i'm planning on is is working with my
daughter she's
she's trying to figure out some way that
we can bring the ceremonies back to the
displaced peoples from the
national parks from the the indigenous
peoples from the national parks so we're
working on that she's got her degree
from uc santa cruz and environmental
studies and economics and she's pursuing
a career in the national park service so
we're trying to see if we can figure out
some way that she can go
to the different parks within the
country and bring back the ceremonies
that we have here in yosemite to the
other parks around the country
so that's something we're working on
awesome awesome thank you bear yeah we
want to thank you for for this this
spiritual film prairie is here it was a
pleasure
my pleasure yeah we really enjoyed this
thank you great we've been speaking with
paul yosemite bear vasquez aka the
double rainbow guy for more on bear
please visit his youtube channel he has
hundreds of videos there um it's
hungrybear9562
um yeah so there's much more than just
this double rainbow video um you know
some really cool videos of of bear in
his life in in yosemite it's beautiful
yeah and trust me even if you're a city
person watching those videos will be
like wow i want to move there i want to
go there so it's it's great to come and
visit and thank you johnson yeah i know
it's a pleasure i appreciate it
yeah it's nice talking to you too bear
and we hope to stay in touch happy
easter yeah happy new year thank you you
know we want to thank our guy jonathan
uh schieffer i keep i keep keep wanting
to say but she for i appreciate it and
it's at jay schifr on twitter um and
we're gonna we're gonna fly out of here
we'd like to thank our guy ronan rosner
for everything he does if you'd like to
hear your project or business mentioned
during one of our shows or in displayed
on our site to advertiserfilmcareers.com
in our radio program please inquire
through filmcars.com via our contact
page and next sunday is our final sunday
here on la talk radio we will be
speaking with sherry candler and john
reese regarding joffrey mavericks of
american dance as well as hybrid cinema
created by filmmaker and author john
reese of think outside the box office
and his book with sherry candler and the
film collaborative selling your film
without selling your soul
yes indeed hybrid cinema was created to
help filmmakers navigate the
ever-changing world of film distribution
and marketing for more on john reese and
sherry candler please visit
johnreese.com
sherrykandler.com and
joffreymovie.com again the film joffrey
mavericks of american dance will be
released shortly i believe uh vod yeah
so yeah it's time to start the 27th of
april something absolutely and as karen
mentioned it's our final film courage
live show um we're sort of evolving into
into new terrain we'll still be around
we'll still be around so we're not going
where we hope you join us and that
pretty much does it for us folks until
next sunday
have a great week
you